استدعوه من التاريخ من قصص الف ليله وليله
ليكون شاهدا على الحاضر السندباد البحري
هذه المره ليكون تميمه رسميا لبطوله خليجي
25 لكره القدم المقامه في البصره جنوبيه
العراق
انتشرت مجسماته في كل مكان مع بدء البطوله
البعض هنا يذكرهم السندباد بايام الصبا
ولا ينكرون انه اختيار ذكي
يعني شخصيه هذه محبوبه لنا من قبل لا
نشوفها هنا
وغير انها هي تاريخ وهي رمز تعتبر
للعراق شخصيه كان اختيارها اختيار يعني
ذكي جدا
ولان شخصيه السندباد اسطوريه في المخيله
العراقيه والعربيه كان اختياره تميمه
لخليجي 25 فكره غايه في الرمزيه والدلاله
اذا انا سندباد كان يشكل جسر المدينه
وترتكز قصص رحلاته على تجاربه تجار من
البصره كانت بضاعتهم مع جزر الهند الشرقيه
والصين وما كان يعتريها من مخاطر واهوال
اختيار الايه السندباد كرمزيه لهذه
الدلاله للدلاله البحريه للدلاله على
الحكايات الاسطوريه للتراث العراقي القديم
الذي يربط العراق بالدول الخليجيه التي
تشترك في هذه البطوله
منظموا البطوله يحرثون على ان تكون تميمه
البطوله منتشره الرقميه من خلال وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ما يعطيها تفاعل اكبر
السندباد البحري اذا يبقى دائما تلك
الشخصيه الاسطوريه العراقيه المرحب بها في
كل وقت وحين وهنا جيء به تميمه ليبقى
شاهدا على بطوله خليجي 25
وشاهدا ايضا على عوده بلاد الرافدين الى
تنظيم البطولات بعد اكثر من اربعه عقود من
الغياب